Jack your IMDB shows that you were an
actor on the Chuck Norris film missing
in action
you played a bouncer do you remember
however small that rule was or large
that rule was do you remember what the
set was like it's a great question but I
think I have to put this straight okay
okay I was never in missing an action
but I was never in the Chuck know as
much as I remember watching I mean I saw
missing in action like when I was in
high school or junior high right and you
know and I have to admit you know it's
like at that age I was sort of a Chuck
Norris you know fan but I'm not in it
when you think about the you know when I
was born versus when I would have had to
have played like a little Vietnamese boy
or it's like a six-year-old I mean
doesn't make any sense
I got it says I was a bouncer right I
know I saw in nineteen whenever that
picture was made which is like 1986 or
something I can't remember what it was I
I would have had to have been no no no
it's it's it's earlier I think I think
the movie is in the earlier 80s I think
anyway I would have been like a 14 year
old bouncer or something like that so I
don't know what happened but like for
the last 15 years or so it has me down
as an actor in missing in action and I
think I tried to correct it and it just
stayed there so now I don't even now now
don't even bother anymore I've been
missing in action so wow I'm so sorry
that's probably it would have been that
would have been cool because I would
have loved to have been on the set of
missing in action I did end up hanging
out with Chuck Norris a little bit
because I ended up directing years later
a show for CBS on Walker Texas Ranger so
I had to go to Texas and spent a couple
of weeks with the production
specifically profiling chuck for for
Walker Texas Ranger but that's about as
close as I got to Chuck Norris
unfortunately I was not
in missing a mistake though in some
sense it's such a way I mean I guess
it's like a good sort of random I mean
it's better than saying you're an extra
and Steel Magnolias or something it's
like it sounds cooler to be a bouncer
but like look at me like how could I
possibly be like even if I at that at my
age now how would you catch me as a
bouncer you know in a in a you know you
know right you know where I can't
remember if they what bar would have
been I don't know if they go to Thailand
and recruit you know person it mmm and
Walsh gets little guns or I don't know
what it is but can you met yeah like me
I'm a bouncer you know in a Bangkok CD
but you know it doesn't really need your
parents permission yeah you have to put
on like the court you know the court you
know like beard you know like Bert court
here okay so is that that totally is a
good eighty-six Chur your first time
it's it's funny because that yeah I
don't remember from us talking about
this us meeting several times before
they have ever mentioning that so no I
didn't because it's moving on but I'm
sure hopefully everything else is true
okay great
yeah all right so what you want to reset
no probably probably won't use it but
that's really funny that the of all
movies because I know day was like oh
yeah I can't wait to hear this oh yeah
no and that's funny because I yeah I
really like I like missing it uh-huh